is out on the streets of berlin looking
for contestants for the euromax world
cup test final
first he's looking for three football
crazy italians but it's harder than he
thought berliners are busy people
finally he's in luck three italians who
are ready to take up the challenge
back at the world cup test in naples the
italian fans were brimming over with
soccer knowledge
in france oxel found out that french
fans knew most about their opponents
finally both teams scored 20 out of a
possible 27 points a draw
so that's why he now needs three more
french fans for the big finale here in
berlin and it's not long before three
frenchmen sign up keen to show off their
soccer skills against team italy
so now i want to see italian fans
cheering
not bad for a first attempt
yes now we want to hear the french cheer
it's up to the onlookers to decide
and the first round goes
to the italians
in the second round the teams can score
points for the best football legs
once again the public decides in favor
of italy and marco's legs
and the third and final task who can
change their jersey fastest and return
with a new one
this time the french team pull it off
we've reached our decision the italian
fans have won the euromax world cup test
can we get another round of applause for
them please
congratulations if that's not an
achievement i don't know what is
the winning prize and the euromax world
cup test is an original ball from this
year's world cup final
congratulations